[Musique]
oui j'ai entendu parler des régionales
d'ailleurs il se demandait si elle
allait être maintenu ou pas je ne savais
pas qu'il y avait des élections ce mois
de juin la de cette année normalement
2000 2021 je vois pas du tout ce que ça
peut être c'est juste au cours des
élections l'année prochaine mais je me
suis pas intéressé aux élections de cet
été j'en connais au moins c'est les
régionales ça doit être ça dont on parle
d'un éventuel report et conseil régional
oui s'il ya des questions ne soient les
transports honnêtement honnêtement non
je sais que il ya des budgets à gérer au
niveau d'un département
un conseil pour aller les territoires en
fait les départements oui je vais aller
voter parce que je vais voter à chaque
élection ce c'est important pour moi non
je serai pas là au mois de juin de cette
année non je ne sais pas encore je
puisque j'étais pas au courant donc je
réfléchirai quand j'entendrai parler
plus en détail
je ne vais pas aller voter parce que
je ne vote plus depuis assez longtemps
quel que soit le scrutin d'ailleurs
alors vous voyez bosmont sourd et
bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
élections départementales et régionales
vous voyez qu'elle a besoin
d'informations encore sur ceux sur ce
genre d'élection et le débat qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir s'il faut
voter aux dates prévues qui sont le 13
et 20 juin prochain ou s'il faut
reporter ces élections en raison de la
crise sanitaire
depuis vendredi les 35000 maires de
france ont été consultés et ils vont
donner leur réponse aujourd'hui pour
savoir s'ils sont en mesure ou pas
d'organiser ces élections alors nous
allons parler de savoir s'il faut ou non
organiser ces élections aux dates
prévues ou leur portée avec anne
perdriau bonjour bonjour patrice bonjour
vous êtes conseiller régional ile de
france sortants de la majorité de
valérie pécresse et vous serez candidate
peut-être les 13 et 20 juin peut-être un
peu plus tôt si si les élections sont
repoussées
bruno myle yens bonjour vous êtes député
modem des yvelines et vous êtes un de
ceux qui sont pour le report des
élections de la même façon de dire que
que le le président de votre parti
françois bayrou jean françois vivier
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le maire de
bures sur yvette et vous êtes le
président du groupe u10 au conseil
régional
et puis nous avons un grand spécialiste
du droit électoral qui est jean-pierre
camby bonjour bonjour vous êtes vous
êtes professeur associé à l'université
de versailles saint quentin et vous êtes
donc un d'un des meilleurs spécialistes
du droit électoral vous me direz si on
peut ou pas reporter les élections s'il
faut le faire et si on pouvait aussi
peut-être changer les modalités de vote
parce que ça ça c'est une question qui
est jointe à la première alors bruno
myle y est je vais commencer avec vous
je disais
les maires sont ont été contactés par le
parlent par le préfet pour savoir s'ils
pouvaient ou pas organiser ces élections
est ce que vous avez vous des retours
dans votre circonscription de ce que
disent les verts alors moi figurez vous
que quand le conseil scientifique a
rendu son avis justement sur ces dates
d'élection j'ai pas attendu la
consultation du gouvernement ni même
celle des associations d'élus puisque
dès le lendemain j'ai envoyé à tous les
maires de ma circonscription le rapport
du haut conseil en leur demandant leur
avis sur ce rapport et quelles
difficultés il voyait à tenir ou pas
d'ailleurs
ces élections les 13 et 20 juin
prochains et paradoxalement j'ai reçu
des réponses qui sont plutôt en faveur
du report à près de 70 % pour ceux qui
m'ont répondu il ya à peu près une
cinquantaine de maires sur les 87 de ma
circonscription
mais j'ai peur que ce résultat ne soit
pas le même que celui que va recevoir le
préfet je m'explique vendredi un
courrier de l'union des maires des
yvelines est parti chez nos amis maires
je vous cite simplement la dernière
phrase que je trouve un petit peu
extraordinaire je vous lis c'est sur le
mail je ne peux pas cacher non plus les
craintes face à un report renouveler et
à ses conséquences sur l'investissement
public de la région et du département et
par conséquent sur la conduite de vos
projets municipaux 500 à tout petit peu
le chantage que dans la lettre
on dit que bien évidemment l'union des
maires des yvelines est plutôt pour le
maintien deux points simplement sur le
permettez patrice parce que j'ai pas
monopoliser la parole d'abord
premièrement il y aurait pas de déni de
démocratie sur ce qui concerne les
régionales puisque je rappelle à tout le
monde quand même qu'on a été élu en
décembre 2015 que cette élection avait
déjà été reporté pour des causes
évidemment de terrorisme et que l'aja
n'avait pas entendu parler
les grands élus personnes avaient poussé
des cris d'orfraie sur ce décalage des
régionales puisque ça a laissé au
candidat au putatif candidat à la
succession des sortants un peu plus de
temps pour préparer
après près leur campagne donc si je
comprends que ça puisse gêner pour les
départementales puisque la l'échéance
est passé déjà depuis sera passé depuis
trois mois en revanche pour les
régionales franchement si on fait ça au
mois d'octobre alors qu'on aurait dû
faire ça au mois de décembre
en théorie il n'ya pas il n'y a pas mort
d'homme voilà c'est tout ce que je
voulais dire en introduction d'une
époque
alors jean françois vivier s'interroge
le évidemment vous êtes le président du
groupe idi au conseil régional
vous êtes aussi maire est ce que vous
avez reçu une même consigne de lyon des
deiber de votre département que celle de
pierrefonds à laquelle bruno médiane
faisait allusion écoutez on n'a pas reçu
de consigne simplement je rappelle quand
même que nos associations
représentatives de mer je parle de
l'association des maires de france
ils sont et récemment l'association des
maires d'île de france ont fait part de
leur position donc je rappelle ces
associations sont composés à la fois
d'élus de toutes tendances politiques et
des élus des villes d'élus des campagnes
et ces deux associations partis d'un
constat oui la situation sanitaire est
tendue mais ça on connaît cette
situation depuis maintenant plus d'un an
oui les conditions d'organisation des
élections dans ce contexte seront
sensibles mais on ne voit pas au nom de
quoi on pourrait à nouveau reporté ce
scrutin au mois d'octobre
sachant que on n'a aucune idée de ce que
sera la situation sanitaire en octobre
et si nous pourrons tout autant
organiser ce type de scrutin dans des
conditions meilleures
donc il ya une question sur les
conditions d'organisation du scrutin
ils sont là qu alors là pour le coup il
faut que le gouvernement travaille avec
les maires les élus locaux
ça c'est très important mais aujourd'hui
je moi maire d'une commune de 10000
habitants
je dirais que la question se pose pour
moitié pour le mois d'octobre
qu'en sera-t-il à ce moment-là difficile
difficile à dire après il ya il ya
d'autres il ya d'autres sujets qu'en est
il de la proximité de scrutin au mois
d'octobre entre une régionale et une
phase i dans ciel est ce que cela peut
influer sur sur les conditions
d'organisation de cette élection
justement ça c'est une autre question à
laquelle j'ai pas forcément de réponses
mais mais en tout cas pour répondre à
votre question l'union des maires de
l'essonne n'a pas donné de consignes
mais pour autant nos associations
représentatives ont donné une position
donc moi j'ai envie de suivre cette
position d'accord donc vous êtes plutôt
pour le maintien on va passer dans un
instant le débat est d'ailleurs ce que
vous disiez c'est à dire est ce qu'il ya
des arrière pensées politiques derrière
ce report on va en parler dans quelques
instants
ce que je vous propose avant pour le
pour lancer ce débat c'est d'écouter le
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines pierre bédier à qui j'ai
demandé s'ils étaient pour ou contre le
report il est contre le report c'est pas
une surprise oui je suis pour le
maintien
parce que la démocratie doit être
respectée
c'est sur le socle de notre de notre vie
en commun alors je suis pour bien
entendu à la réserve expresse que mes
choses que je ne crois pas si les
mesures prises par le président de la
république et le gouvernement ne
permettez pas de faire baisser
l'épidémie là si l'épidémie de flamber
il faudrait se reposer la question mais
comme je crois que le président de la
république et son gouvernement vont
réussir à endiguer cette épidémie en
particulier en réussissant la
vaccination
et puis après tous les efforts seront
faits les français les yvelinois eh bien
je crois que il faut en passer par cette
élection parce que ce grand moment
démocratique est nécessaire
alors on va examiner un petit peu les
arguments des déjections pour le report
il ya un certain nombre de maires qui
disent ça va être très difficile de
organisée de manière démocratique ce
scrutin d'abord comment trouver des
assesseurs est-ce qu'il faut les
vaccinés et comment allez vous faire
vacciner avant le scrutin est assez
longtemps avant le scrutin pour qu'ils
ne risquent rien qu'est ce que vous
répondez à cette rumeur
alors on a un problème mais qu'on avait
déjà avant même la pandémie qui est
l'organisation des élections
départementales et régionales en même
temps parce que ça oblige à dédoubler
les bureaux de vote
c'est comme ça c'est fait on le savait
il faudra faire avec
pour ce qui est de la vaccination ils
ont raison ces mères et naturellement
c'est quand même pas très compliqué
d'organiser la vaccination de ses
assesseurs dans les quinze jours qui
précèdent le scrutin alors deuxième
argument celui de la campagne c'est de
dire aux périodes en effet de
confinement et on sait pas jusqu'à quand
exactement ça va durer ça va être très
compliqué de mener une campagne
électorale c'est vrai ça va être des
campagnes différentes
il va y avoir provoqué de numérique on
en a tous pris un peu l'habitude on
travaille et touche maintenant largement
télétravail une vision conférence nous
électeurs font très habitué maintenant
donc oui on va faire campagne de façon
un petit peu différente c'est pas idéal
mais le résultat est plus important que
les moyens le résultat c'est qu'il faut
impérativement le renouvellement des
exécutifs départementaux et régionaux
ne serait-ce aussi faux que pour des
raisons économiques les régions et les
départements sont des principaux
investisseurs en hausse sphère publique
et investissent plus que les pas et on a
besoin de l'investissement pour relancer
la machine économique
notre troisième argument alors on l'a vu
un petit peu avec l'expérience des
municipales c'est évidemment un risque
d'abstention qui est encore plus grand
que le municipal parce que le municipal
c'est de l'élection préféré des français
sur les départementales des régionales
et se mobilise généralement un peu moins
lie en gros risque d'une énorme
abstention et donc
et de la légitimité des élus on a connu
pour les élections municipales une assez
forte abstention liée à la pandémie
ça n'a pas empêché les exécutifs
municipaux de se mettre en place le
principe républicain c'est que les
absents ont toujours tort donc quand on
a vu des villes basculer parce que
l'électorat ce n'était pas assez
mobilisé bien que ça serve de leçon à
chacun on ne peut pas arrêter la
démocratie et la démocratie passe par le
respect des échéances
il faut vraiment des conditions
totalement exceptionnel pour reporter
ses échéances et j'ajouterais patrice
que les reporter quand alors fait signer
dié à bitam et thermales
donc ça voudrait dire les reporté en
septembre ou octobre
septembre octobre rien ne nous dit que
la pandémie sera fini
septembre octobre on sait bien qu'il ya
le grand rendez-vous des de l'élection
présidentielle et que le débat commence
toujours six mois il faut donc remporté
sa après les élections présidentielles
mais après les élections présidentielles
il ya les élections législatives on va
pas passer l'année 2022 a voté tous les
3 mois ou tous les deux mois
donc je crois que c'est plus raisonnable
il ya un risque d'abstention et
profitons des médias comme le vôtre ton
dire aux français vous tenez fait voter
aller voter le vote est essentielle
merci beaucoup pierre bédier alors c'est
le débat évidemment faut-il maintenir ou
reporter ces élections on accueille
philippe benassaya bonjour bonjour vous
êtes député lrd des yvelines bruno
milliet nous disait il ya quelques
quelques minutes que 70% des maires de
sa circonscription étaient favorables
report est ce que vous avez un retour
des maires de votre circonscription
oui c'est le contraire dans la
circonscription j'ai pas le pourcentage
précis mais on est plutôt à front
renversé dans la 11e circonscription
c'est que les maires majoritairement
mais il ya moins de yang commune que
dans la queue dans la circonscription de
bruno
j'ai beaucoup moins commune puisque j'en
ai sept mais majoritairement les élus
locaux puisque j'ai pas consulté que les
mères mais également les élus locaux
sont plutôt favorables à un maintien des
élections en joie et vous vous l'êtes
aussi évidemment alors demain vous allez
y ait une séance à l'assemblée nationale
sur ce sujet comment ça va se passer
quel est le pouvoir de l'assemblée sur
la ce la tenue ou pas de ces élections
au jusqu'à maintenant le pouvoir de
l'assemblée il est je dirais consultatif
c'est à dire que en général les
décisions sont prises probablement avant
et ensuite il y à un débat qui
s'effectue à l'assemblée nationale mais
qui ne bouleverse pas mais ça c'est la
règle démocratique et une majorité et
une opposition nos avis nos avis sont en
sont entendus mais pas forcément pris en
compte
mais voilà il y aura un débat et puis
ensuite on verra comment ça se passe
mais je suis plutôt favorable en effet
au maintien des élections en juin
je pense que c'est plus important mais
pierre bédier a presque tout dit sur sur
les problématiques de report d'élections
en septembre ou en octobre à quelques
mois d'une présidentielle
et puis je suis pas favorable aux
tripatouillages comme ça constitutionnel
des élections ces élections peuvent se
tenir les pays européens ont voté
également concomitamment à nos élections
donc je pense que on peut très bien avec
beaucoup de prudence bien sûr et
beaucoup de respect des gestes barrières
effectuer ces élections bruno myle yens
vous êtes donc favorable au report est
ce que il y avait quand même cette
question qui est importante c'est que la
question de la vie de la démocratie on a
vu l'abstention aux municipales pour les
régionales et pour les départementales
elles risquent d'être encore beaucoup
plus forts de cette abstention
mais moi même mes inquiétudes sont
plutôt là dessus d'abord je rappelle
tout pour les élections régionales n'a
pas de déni démocratique encore une fois
puisque normalement le mandat des élus
régionaux court jusqu'en décembre 2021
bien évidemment il faut qu'on fasse les
élections avant parce que là on est trop
proche de l'élection présidentielle donc
ya pas d y a pas de déni démocratique
pour ce qui concerne les régionales où
pourrait le considérer qu à main
si on retarde encore pour les
départementales puisque là les élections
réduit avoir lieu en mars et on est déjà
en retard
ça c'est le premier point deuxième point
j'ai très peur en tout cas moi de ce que
j'ai pu recevoir comme comme elle je lui
ai dit j'ai pas attendu les
consultations des uns et des autres pour
faire les miennes ce que j'ai reçu comme
avis c'est plutôt de dire au mois de
juin
mais faire des élections quelle qu'elle
soit d'ailleurs les français seront pas
là parce que ça fait plus d'un an qu'ils
sont sous cloche et si ça se desserre
comme on l'espère tous et c'est aussi un
des arguments qui plaident en faveur au
moins pour les régionales et moi je ne
le suis pas persuadé que le gouvernement
soit d'accord avec moi d'ailleurs un
jour dit jeudi à l'intention aussi de
philippe le gouvernement et pas
forcément s'aligner sur ce que je dis
mais les régionales une différence entre
la république en mars et le modem
d'ailleurs à cette heure je pense pas
que ça se situe là là je pense que c'est
vraiment des d intime conviction a
évidemment il ya les partis politiques
qui jouent on n'y a pas de souci moi
j'étais même pour un report beaucoup
plus lointain mais bon ça c'est mon avis
que que personnel mais ce qui plaide
aussi pour fin septembre ou début
octobre
c'est que la lave oxydation rajoutant
son plein les français ont quand même
passé un été un petit peu plus proches
de la normale que ce qu'ils ont vécu
depuis un an et demi et aurait été
peut-être plus en comment dire plus à
l'ecoute en tout cas de tous les
candidats des programmes présentés et
puis motivé pour aller voter qu'au mois
de juin donc à ce risque le dit papa
d'illégitimité mais d'une abstention
très très forte
je vous rappelle quand même que quand il
ya eu les élections législatives en 2010
est l'abstention avait été très forte
évidemment on nous a tous taxés de
députés est légitime je ne sais pas ce
que diront les conseillers régionaux
élus s'ils sont élus avec moins de 40 %
des inscrits voilà c'est juste ça on
prend ce risque là mais pierre bédier a
raison quand il dit ceux qui n'ont pas
voté ont tort évidemment les asiatiques
toujours tort mais mais mais quand même
dans le ressenti il ya ce danger là et
encore une fois moi je décorais les deux
élections très très clairement et je
pense que le débat je termine là dessus
le débat est important chez lipp à
raison philippe benassaya raison notre
avis ne sera que consultatif
mais là je vois quand même mal le
gouvernement se passer de l'avis
consultatif des deux chambres
parce que là c'est quand même sur la
démocratie
de l'apei qu'on joué sur les élections
sur les institutions ça va être quand
même compliqué de ne pas tenir compte
des votes chez still consultatif
alors je vais je vais interroger un père
brio et jean-pierre combes dans un
instant b philippe benassaya doit nous
quittez donc juste une dernière question
est ce que philippe benassaya vous
verriez dans leur port s'il avait lieu
un calcul politique au delà de du calcul
sanitaire enfin au réseau de la
situation sanitaire
bon je sais pas si on peut parler de
calcul mais en tout cas il ya une peur
il ya une peur probablement de
probablement de l'abstention comme le
dit bruno mais également moi je pars pas
perdant je me dis que une élection il
faut aller chercher les électeurs il
faut les faire on avait dit ça pour mars
2020 pour les municipales vous allez
voir c'est vrai qu'il ya pas une
participation extraordinaire pour
exagérer c'est vrai mais il ya eu quand
même une participation il y aura une
participation également joint 6 et 6 est
maintenue d'abord je rappelle il ya les
départementales et les régionales en
juin dont il ya deux élections
totalement déconnecté c'est pas les
mêmes logiques de vote d'ailleurs voix
originales comme on vote départementale
ce sont deux stratégies différentes des
régionales c'est plutôt en guadeloupe
j'ai envie de dire de bilan régional
certes mais également c'est un tour de
chauffe nationale j'ai l'impression
alors que le département d'all-star
votre très local sa mode de gens qu'on
connaît le sujet de proximité etc
non je sais pas si c'est un calcul mais
bon on peut pas on peut pas non plus
écarté le sujet le problème sanitaire
sera peut-être également présent en
octobre qui le sait avec les variants
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui on ne sait pas
si on sait création sera sorti en
octobre donc on va pas reportée sine
aidiez constamment les élections les
élections parce qu'il y à risque il va
falloir maintenant vivre avec et vivre
avec il faut prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour que la démocratie
revivent repartent et comprennent des
risques je suis désolé de le dire
prennent des risques pour que cette
démocratie passe maintenant aussi si
c'est reporté en octobre il y aura
toujours cette espèce de petite musique
arrière pensée de calcul électoral
forcément j'entends également aussi je
suis pas complètement sourgentin
également certains élus nos marges qui
disent que mieux vaut peut-être prendre
les élections en octobre
en juin je
je répète ce que j'entends moi moi ça
m'est égal juin ou octobre
ça ne changera pas le les résultats
électoraux je préfère ça se passe en 2
juin bruno horizons pour les régionales
c'est vrai qu'on est encore dans le on
est encore dans le timing dans le délai
les départementales on n'est plus dans
les délais en juin pour voter il faut
voter donc moi j'aime bien que le
calendrier électoral soit respectée il
comprend mal il faut pas avoir peur des
élections
faut pas avoir peur des électeurs il
faut pas avoir peur des résultats il
faut y aller pour faire campagne
merci beaucoup je vais vous libérer
philippe benassaya quoi je sais pas si
le mot et est adapté puisque vous allez
vous étonner je crois à la prison de
bois d'arcy m'enfin bon je vous dirai ça
croque maison d'arrêt de bois d'arcy mes
premiers points et celle de revenir chez
des pins oui oui tact et fabrice escale
à l'est mais je reçois gérard larcher
donc il faut que j'y aille vers sidi
yahya un père brio il ya une question
qui se pose vous êtes
candidate avec avec valérie pécresse il
ya la question rom de la campagne
électorale la comau comment ça se passe
c'est ce que vous êtes en mesure de
faire une campagne électorale
alors je vais être un petit peu plus
cash
parce que j'ai vraiment une liberté de
parole je suis citoyenne aussi avant
d'être élu et je voulais quand même dire
un petit mot sur l'heureux sur le report
ou non des élections
je voulais quand même dire que pour moi
en tant que citoyenne et lui ce serait
vraiment un aveu d'échec de l'exécutif
et mais je trouve que la ficelle est un
peu grosse
je trouve que quand on s'engage à
rouvrir les écoles fin avril les bars
les restaurants mi-mai qu'on s'engage à
avoir 30 millions de vaccinés mi juin
je ne vois absolument pas pourquoi on
repas on reporterait à nouveau ces
élections est ce que je voulais dire
aussi c'est qu'en fait en tant que
citoyenne est élu on a vraiment
l'impression comme les commerces ou y
aller les essentiels les nains essentiel
que les élections locales sont vraiment
des élections non essentiel et c'est à
nouveau on retrouve ce travers deux de
l'exécutif qui qui n'a pas grande
considération pour les élus locaux qui
n'a pas grande considération pour tous
ceux qui bossent tous les jours sur le
terrain en tant qu'élus locaux
on travaille sur des domaines
extrêmement concret et je pense que
tous les tous les pays européens gérard
larcher 10 et 13 pays européens ont voté
ou vont voter on ne voit vraiment pas la
raison d'un nouveau report de ces
élections
vraiment voilà donc ça c'est pour la
partie report pour la partie campagne
en fait on fait une campagne d'un tout
autre d'une toute autre génération que
j'allais dire donc on a adapté on a
totalement adapter nos méthodes de
campagne on fait des révisions au lieu
de tracter en boîte un ce qui nous
empêche pas de rencontrer aussi des gens
sur le terrain
donc voilà donc je ne vois pas vraiment
des raisons particulières qui nous
empêcheraient on va on va faire nos
courses dans les magasins essentiel on
rencontre des gens
non je ne vois pas de raisons
pertinentes pour pour reporter à nouveau
cette cette campagne et cette élection
alors avant d'interroger brute 2008 pour
qu'il vous réponde peut-être on va
peut-être faire un point peu juridique
avec jean-pierre combi d'abord est ce
que l'europe aurait les élégantes bruno
beliën soulignait la différence entre le
vôtre les régionales et les
départementales
est-ce que les départementales par
exemple on peut les reporter signer ou
pas est ce qu'on a le droit qui décident
de ce report l'assemblée le sénat vont
discuter mardi mercredi mais est-ce que
c'est l'exécutif qui est responsable de
ce report peut-être vous nous éclairer
sur ce plan juridique alors d'une part
je voudrais dire qu'il faut distinguer
le débat qui aura lieu au parlement qui
est une déclaration du gouvernement
suivie à un départ ce vote est
effectivement purement consultatif mais
en revanche
si l'on voulait reporter une échéance
électorale quelconque
la première condition c'est qu'il le
flot d'une loi
la preuve c'est qu'on a d'ores et déjà
reporté par la loi du 22 juillet dernier
les élections départementales et
régionales
donc on serait là dans un cas inédit de
nouveaux reports de record dû reprendre
elle a un deuxième condition c'est que
non seulement et de loi doit être voté
alors j'entends bien que le gouvernement
pourra voir sa majorité encore que on
voit bien que ce ne sont pas des
clivages forcément traditionnels qui
sont là en cause mais en toute hypothèse
il faudrait que noah soit votée deuxième
condition il faut que cette loi soit
constitutionnelle et le conseil
constitutionnel nous dit quoi
s'agissant des reports des élections il
nous dit d'abord qu'il faut un motif
motifs impérieux motif d'intérêt général
je ne vois pas bien où ils seraient dans
le fait que la situation sanitaire
serait plus ou moins dégradée en juin
on n'en sait rien ensuite le conseil
constitutionnel nous a toujours dit que
les reports de v au regard des règles de
démocratie être exceptionnel pour une
durée limitée
hélas une fois encore je le répète on
serait dans un cas inédit que le conseil
constitutionnel serait amené
nécessairement à trancher j'ajoute une
dernière chose sur la campagne
les campagnes électorales sont d'ores et
déjà commencé elles sont des luttes et
est par conséquent il n'est pas possible
me semble-t-il de reporter à nouveau ses
campagnes sans une fois encore modifier
profondément la loi elle-même juste une
précision pardon la loi du 22 février à
laquelle vous faisiez allusion qui a
reporté ces élections au mois de juin
est-ce qu'elle ne laissait pas ouverte
la possibilité de les reporter à nouveau
en fonction de l'état de la situation
sanitaire
alors naturellement à chaque fois c'est
comme pour les municipales
vous allez cette soupape cette soupape
consiste à dire nous demandons la vie du
conseil scientifique
mais en l'espèce la vie du conseil
scientifique n'est pas négatif il a été
négatif pour les élections des français
résidant de france mais cette fois ci il
est positif sous conditions sanitaires
par conséquent cette soupape ne joue pas
en l'état actuel brilliance telle
passion là ce que de dire jean pierre
convient parce que il pose le problème
sur un plan constitutionnel avec
semble-t-il d'aidé dire que le report ne
se serait peut-être retoquée par le
conseil constitutionnel
le lanaudois mannequin mais jean-pierre
convient tout à fait raison et je ne
fais pas contre lui bien évidemment mais
pour pour répondre un petit peu aux
questions moi je me pose aussi d'un
point de vue purement pratique elle le
voyait bien si on doit vacciner comme ça
une double échéance une double élection
suédois vaccinés les assesseurs on a
fait les calculs c'est entre 600 et 700
mille personnes à abattre
c'est énorme et c'est pas et c'est pas
comme le dit je suis désolé de
contredire pierre bédier s'est pas
simplement quinze jours après puisque
les effets des vaccins ce soit à peu
près efficace soit en trois semaines
jean françois et annecy ont eu des idées
qui ont lu des des postes au sein des
municipalités savent très bien que on
trouve un de ses assesseurs
des fois on les trouve trois quatre
jours avant avant le vote et et en
allant chercher tout le monde parce que
des fois c'est compliqué de trouver des
assesseurs or là il faut les multiplier
par 2 est un plus pour les vacciner
trois semaines avant ça c'est la
première chose deuxième chose comment
vous avez expliqué dites-moi quand vous
allez expliquer aux proches au pot
sied aux pompiers aux soignants aux
caissières à tous ces gens qu'on veut
vacciner en priorité parce qu'ils sont
au contact direct de la population et
que ce qui risque le plus de contrats
tels virus qui courent toujours
on va faire passer entre 600 et 700
milles assesseurs en priorité voire même
les candidats de toutes les listes
régionales parce que pour pour le coup
allons allons jusqu'au bout et on sait
très bien régionales et départementales
d'ailleurs on sait très bien que pour
les régionales ce sont six sont des
listes départementales à plus de 20
personnes dans 23 personnes pour les
îles il me semble vingt-trois personnes
mènent plus d'ailleurs 29 héééé voilà
donc moins en termes de moi je me place
simplement en termes de logistique en
termes de logistique jeu quand je
parlais de la décorrélation entre les
deux élections
pour moi ça ferait sens ce serait plus
simple d'organiser au mois de juin et
moi je suis pour ça j'ai pas de souci
là-dessus les départementales parce
qu'on a déjà passé l'échéance
démocratique de mars et peut-être mettre
paix régionale en septembre octobre ce
qui ferait pas une grosse différence
puisque je vous raconte encore une fois
et le mandat des élus régionaux court
jusqu'en décembre 2021 voilà c'est
simplement pour décorer les deux
faciliter la vie des mères est peut-être
donner un petit peu plus d'intérêt à ces
élections aux électeurs voilà ça c'est
pas un avis constitutionnel monsieur
courbis et si mon avis à moi de on va
dire de logique
vigier en perdriau juste un mot
jean-pierre combi au plus haut pour est
juridiquement découpler les élections
départementales et les élections
régionales
oui bien sûr mais à nouveau il faut
nécessairement une loi soit votée on le
prévoit je voudrais ajouter un élément
sur le report c'est que on a de toutes
les façons une date qui est fixée alors
là pour le coup par la constitution elle
même c'est la date de l'élection
présidentielle
elle peut plus on aura d'autres
échéances
plus on se trouvera dans des situations
problématiques
notamment au regard des comptes de
campagne entre des personnes qui
seraient candidates ou frais candidature
pour une élection présidentielle et
serait candidate ou soutien de
candidature pour des élections
départementales ou régionales ça posera
un inextricable problème pour distinguer
les comptes de campagne deux candidats à
la présidentielle et les comptes de
campagne qui doivent démarrer au 1er
juillet et les comptes de campagne des
élections régionales et départementales
qui ont déjà démarré juste par curiosité
pardon mais si par malheur la situation
sanitaire s'aggraver
on peut imaginer report des élections
présidentielles pour l'imaginer il faut
réviser la constitution
il n'y a pas d'autre solution les dates
découle directement de l'article 7 de la
constitution gens feront vous l'imaginez
en politique au liban
bien entendu si la situation si la
situation se dégrader à nouveau il
faudrait prendre une mesure d'extrême
urgence
mais le blocage juridique c'est la
constitution m je me souviens qu'aux
états unis savaient était il en avait
été question au trump un moment
voulaient voulait reporter mais je crois
que c'était absolument impossible selon
la constitution américaine france à
béziers ce que disait bruno myle y est
justement sur les assesseurs
vous les trouvez comment et puisque vous
êtes maire débur série vous voulez
trouver comment et à quel délai est ce
que ces bases c'est pas faux ce qui dit
on les trouve généralement à quelques
jours du scrutin papa papa trois
semaines avant ou pas un mois avant j'ai
plusieurs points de désaccord avec mon
ami bruno myle yens que je vais essayer
de résumer d'abord c'est la première
fois que j'entends que les électeurs ne
serait pas présent à une élection
instructeur dès lors qu il est convoqué
je pense les français ont toujours été
là
et ont répondu présent au scrutin le
problème effectivement c'est que on a
affaire aux deux scrutins départementaux
et régionaux qui intéresse pardonnez-moi
le moins les français dans le avec les
élections européennes dans le la liste
des scrutins des scrutins nationaux
pour autant je ne crois pas une seconde
que tout le monde sera parti au mois de
juin dès lors qu' il y aurait un
desserrement des contraintes sanitaires
ce sera à nous aussi de aux
gouvernements aux élus aux instances
qu'on doit renouveler de faire la
promotion de ce scrutin
on sait de toute façon on sait on l'a vu
pour les municipales qu'il y aura
vraisemblablement moins de votants mais
il y en aura tout autant moins warnock
top si jamais c'était reporter le
deuxième point avec lequel j'ai un
désaccord avec nos milieux c'est la
question de la vaccination nécessaire
d'aider des assesseurs et d'une pénurie
programmée de vaccins aujourd'hui les
chiffres qui sont annoncés par le
gouvernement dise le contraire parce que
je pense qu'il ya eu de gros effort de
fait pour obtenir des vaccins
nécessaires j'en veux pour preuve que le
miz la santé a annoncé ce week-end
d'ouverture de la vaccination à partir
d'aujourd'hui aux plus de 55 ans pour te
pas imaginer une seconde que cela elle
met en pénurie pour vacciner des
assesseurs dont on sait pour une très
large majorité d'entre eux qu'ils sont
bien au delà au delà de l'âge de 55 ans
donc moi pour moi ce n'est pas le sujet
de la nécessaire vaccination et qui je
pense est importante pour les assesseurs
moi je pense que les assesseurs on peut
les trouver
parce qu'on a des militants dans l'eau
ville qui se font toujours un point
d'honneur à participer au scrutin je
pense par contre que l'organisation du
scrutin les lieux dans quel dans
lesquelles doit devrait se tenir ce
scrutin
il faut bien en parler entre le
gouvernement et les élus locaux parce
qu'il ya sûrement des décisions à
prendre par rapport aux écoles qui
accueillent le plus souvent ces scrutins
et puis je voudrais revenir tout ce qu'a
dit tout à l'heure pierre bédier
l'important c'est de se dire on donne
legault à une date on donne legault à la
date du mois de juin
si d'ici là il ya une flambée si les
chiffres restent alarmants voir la
contamination augmente et bien dans ce
cas là on prend une décision nationale
en connaissance de cause qui marque la
possibilité de tenir le scrutin
mais aujourd'hui à mon sens on n'en est
pas encore là albert brio il ya quand
même ce risque que se livrent une
williams qui est celui de l'abstention
on a vu aux élections municipales
peut-être parfois des élections faussées
par cette abstention est ce que vous ne
craignez pas que la même chose se
produise aux élections départementales
régionales
alors je pense qu'on a absolument plus
dans le même état d'esprit que en mars
2020 où il y avait vraiment l'apparition
du cordat virus on ne savait pas ce que
c'était
ça a été tout le monde était pétrifié
tétanisés par cette annonce qui est
intervenue quasiment l'avant veille du
déplacement dans les bureaux de vote et
donc évidemment il ya eu une abstention
massive et donc beaucoup de ce scrutin
qui n'ont pas été du tout significatif
d'une d'un vrai engagement de la
population pour un candidat
moi je pense que c'est avec des
attitudes comme ça qu'on finit par par
suscité l'abstention je trouve que on
est vraiment dans un exemple on joue
vraiment avec la démocratie et c'est pas
du tout à l'honneur de notre président
de la république je gérard larcher le
soulignait en disant que c'est quand
même un exécutif qui régulièrement
contourne parlement par le recours aux
ordonnances
il évalue et même le nombre de textes à
plus de 50% et je pense que là il ya un
vrai vrai
un vrai sujet de sur le si vous voulez
le risque d'abstention par ce type
d'attitude et après le risque de
défiance ou de ou de non utilité
vis-à-vis des élus quand on quand on vit
ce type ce type d'épisodes
et puis je voulais dire aussi sur vous
aviez posé tout à l'heure la question
patrice yat il y at il une idée derrière
la tête et que tiff et je dirais qu
après qu après de lévriers pécresse
voilà voilà
et après 2 2 épisodes marquants de ce
week end d'une part donc c'est cette
consultation précipité vis-à-vis des
maires de vendredi soir à lundi matin
et puis le sondage du parisien quand
même
le sondage du parisien où on voit que
les intentions de vote elles sont à 34
cents pour valérie pécresse va perdre 1
9% pour laurent saint martin est donc
effectivement j'imagine qu'il ya un gros
stress dans dans l'exécutif et pompons
mais tous les moteurs en route pour pour
y aller pour ne pas y aller
plus exactement voilà puis dernière
chose je pense que quand on veut on peut
la vaccination des assesseurs si on veut
le faire on peut le faire
or pour l'instant et depuis un an
aucun protocole n'a été même étudié pour
on savait que ces élections allaient
avoir lieu
aucun protocole n'est étudiée et je
pense que peut-être une idée vous savez
qu'on a des réserves civique ou des gens
s'engagent et bien pour les assesseurs
pourquoi ne fait-on pas appel à la
réserve civique pour que les gens il
n'ya pas plus citoyen il ya peu plus il
n'ya pas plus civique quinqua vote
pourquoi ferait pas appel à ces
personnes voilà c'est une idée d'une
possibilité
j'ai oublié de vous laisserai pour et
puis on va passer quand même hein
autre question qui est importante est ce
qu'il faudrait pas aussi ouvrir les
modalités de vote pour les élections
mais peut-être une réponse à ce que
viennent de dire les enfonce un vivier
et un père brio non moi j'entends bien
ce que vous dites
évidemment ce n'est pas impossible que
j'aie jamais dit que c'était impossible
d'ailleurs de vacciner entre 600 et 700
milles assesseurs vous n'êtes pas
entendu son bras gauche
c'est totalement possible avec les
réserves qu'on va avoir je dis
simplement qu'il faut le faire trois
semaines avant les élections et ça ça
peut avoir pour avoir des complications
pour pouvoir il a retrouvé tous ses
assesseurs et puis c'est comment les
gens percevront ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui prioritaire que pour des
élections des assesseurs soient
prioritaires par rapport à ses justes ça
c'est pas le fait de pouvoir le faire ou
pas bien sûr qu'on peut le faire si
c'est pas un problème je vais revenir
sur un point sur toutes les démocraties
qui ont voté effectivement en pleine
pandémie je voudrais quand même rappeler
à mes collègues que toutes ces
démocraties on recourt aussi aux ventes
par correspondance
nous l'avions demandé avec le groupe
modem et démocrates à l'assemblée
nationale ça nous a été refusé toutes
ces démocraties ont les votes par
correspondance inscrit dans leur
institution depuis très longtemps donc
effectivement ça facilite totalement le
vote même dans un cas d'urgence
sanitaire ou d'urgence terroriste enfin
tout ce qu'on peut imaginer comme
urgences qui font que c'est compliqué de
maintenir un bureau de vote en
présentiel dernier point par rapport à
ce que peuvent dire les maires ou et où
les cycles rien à l'instant je reçois je
reçois un mail jeudi les consultations
sur une des communes de ma
circonscription une commune 3975
habitants 1831 se sont prononcés 1279
sont pour un report des élections et 552
pour le maintien avec des réponses
paraît-il assez virulente de personnes
qui trouvent scandaleux d'organiser des
élections
à ce moment là alors qu'ils vivent sous
plage depuis un an moi je vous dise
qu'il est remonté terrain je ne suis pas
en train de raconter des sottises
maintenant que je suis quelqu'un qui
connaît que vous faites c'est un calcul
d'heures de savoir si on peut ou pas
organiser ces élections pour répondre à
un père brio pourrait pas intervenir sur
le fait que la majorité présidentielle
vous
avoir plus de temps pour éventuellement
gagner des régions interbrew on me
connaît bien c'est que je suis pas né de
la dernière pluie et que l' avance
considérable qu'a pris valérie pécresse
il ya de fortes chances qu'elle la
concerne que je traduis aller pour
gagner donc je ne pense pas que le fait
de reporter je parle que des régionales
du mois de juin au mois d'octobre au
derrière de manière considérable les
résultats attendus par les uns et par
les autres
donc ça pour moi c'est un faux argument
est là je relance le débat donc sur les
modalités de vote vrai que je trouve
dommage qu'en 2021 on n'est pas accès à
d'autres modalités de vote que le
présentiel
on a déjà les procurations
san jose états-unis le vote le vote par
correspondance et existe depuis la fin
de la guerre de sécession et il n'y a
jamais eu de preuves avérés de fraude
si on avait eu ça on la demandait bien
avant ne nous dit pas qu'on n'a pas
anticipé en voyait venir
on a demandé bien avant notre groupe on
a posé la question on a même fait un
débat là-dessus à l'assemblée nationale
pour avoir le vote par correspondance
il a été rejeté quand je m'en remets à
la décision de l'assemblée nationale et
du sénat
mais c'est dommage qu'on ait pas cet
outil là parce que là du coup il y
aurait plus de contestation possible
puisque tout le monde pourrait voter en
son âme et conscience
le plus chez lui voilà alors va juste
pour passer à ce cette partie sur les
modalités de vote
[Musique]
jean pierre corby d'abord 1,1 point je
crois que on parlait de la participation
ce que disait pierre bédier les absents
ont toujours tort juridiquement il a
raison c'est à dire que une élection il
faut il faut quoi il faut une
participation minimale ou pas pour être
élue participation minimale pour être
élus n'ont jamais dans aucune
circonstance participation éventuelle
pour être au second tour notamment aux
municipales oui évidemment
elles peuvent
la densité que les danois mais le
conseil constitutionnel a jugé à propos
des municipales l'année dernière que le
taux de participation n'était pas un
critère déterminant de l'élection
elle-même ce n'est pas en fonction du
nombre des participants en plus tôt
c'est en fonction du nombre des votants
que se détermine l'élection et non pas
en fonction du nombre des inscrits alors
parlons de ses modalités vous même vous
êtes assez réticent vous êtes
spécialiste du rectorat la série de dix
ans à l'ouverture d'autres modalités de
vote pourquoi alors il ya plusieurs
raisons d'abord la symbolique le fait de
se rendre aux urnes depuis la 3ème
république est fondamentale ensuite
lorsque vous votez en pour reprendre
l'expression la mode en présentiel
vous êtes certain de la bonne
destination de votre vote vous êtes
certain de c'est vous même qui mettez
votre enveloppe
dès lors qu'on introduit des modalités
distanti l on tombe sur plusieurs
problématiques première problématique
vous avez incontestablement un risque
d'erreur si on prévoit à la fois un vote
par correspondance et à vote à l'urne
des personnes peuvent très bien avoir
voté par correspondance puis se rendre à
l'urne et c'est sa pause les
d'incontestables d'incontestables
problèmes techniques et ensuite tout et
matérialisation implique un moment donné
vous soyez privé du fait que c'est vous
même qui voter alors il faut inventer
pour aller dans le sens de ce que
souhaite monsieur 1000 yens
il faudrait inventer des systèmes dans
lesquels
lloret un vote électronique mais dans
lesquels on se rendrait tout de même aux
surnoms ont bien des systèmes dans
lesquels on garantir et à l'électeur
mais ça je n'en connais pas que son vote
par correspondance et bien 126 donc
risquant d' iphone risques de piratage
si on a arrêté le vote par
correspondance à l'époque uniquement
postale dans ce pays en 1975 c'est
uniquement à cause des risques de froid
et pourtant regardez en allemagne ça
existe et je crois que la cour fédérale
a décidé de ne plus examiner les
plaintes de fraude parce qu'il est qu'il
n'a pas donc ça peut exister à
l'étranger jean françois vivier est
hyper brio sur sur ses modalités de vote
est ce que vous êtes partisan d'une
ouverture enfin d'une modernisation de
ses modalités de vote en tout cas moi
écouter je rejoins ce que ce qu'a dit
tout à l'heure
bruno aussi aujourd'hui c'est vrai c'est
vrai monsieur le professeur vient de le
rappeler il y a une histoire française
du dimanche électoral qui est
profondément enracinée dans la grille
politique on voit que le dimanche c'est
le jour n'est pas non plus choisi au
hasard il ya d'autres démocraties dans
lesquels on vote un jour de semaine
là c'est un cetain c'est un moment très
fort et pour nous les élus locaux pour
vous les maires qui organisons ces
dimanche et bien nous savons combien nos
concitoyens ils sont attachés la
question c'est qu'on vit aujourd'hui
dans un monde dématérialisé de plus en
plus
qui aurait pensé qu'un jour hors empire
et nos feuilles d'impôts par voie
dématérialisée sans envoyer un document
papier pour le vote il me semble
qu'aujourd'hui
on doit trouver le moyen sécurisé de
pouvoir voter en distance yale alors
avec effectivement prenant en compte
tous les écueils qui a incité monsieur
le professeur tout à l'heure mais il me
semble que ça doit aussi regarder
d'ailleurs depuis le début de la
pandémie dans nos collectivités locales
eh bien il est vrai que certaines encore
réunion se tienne en présentiel et il ya
des réunions qui se tiennent en
visioconférence et pour lesquelles le
vote est organisé et nous arrivons à
voter de façon je dirais sécurisé et et
abhisit donc moi je pense qu'il va
falloir se pencher le très clairement
sur ces la question sur ces bateaux ne
perdrions alors tout à fait d'accord
avec toi jean françois en attendant on
voit que dans des pays comme l'espagne
par exemple puisqu'on n'aura pas le
temps évidemment d'organiser ses
modalités non dans l'immédiat donc il ya
il ya des désorganisations qui sont
faites sur plusieurs jours ou en
réservant des créneaux aux plus fragiles
donc c'est aussi une possibilité
et puis troisième point patrice vous
parliez de vous preniez comme exemple
l'allemagne pas de fils croyez vous
vraiment que la mentalité la culture
française peut être comparée à celle du
coeur donc en allemagne où il ya des
choses avec iad il ya des endroits où il
ya des fraudes quand même même avec le
vote dans le dos les dans les urnes
excusez moi pas tu es juste une
précision quand je parlais de se pencher
sur cette question du vote
dématérialisée à distance il s'agit bien
entendu d'une démarche à entreprendre à
un moment où il n'y a pas d'enjeux
électoraux c'est bien sûr la banalise
héros de ce travail c'est après la
présidentielle et qu'on se travaille
sereinement sur 7 sur cette question
très bien bruno peut-être un dernier mot
là dessus
le parlement pourrait saisir quand même
deux
2 nous avons déjà nous avons déjà eu un
débat là-dessus puisque l'on a perdu que
je suis bien je viens donc on l'a perdue
le débat mais on l'avait fait pourtant
on l'avait inscrit suffisamment
longtemps à l'avancé puisque on était en
plein je crois que c'était à l'automne
dernier et on était en plein dans une
situation sanitaire qui nous laissait
déjà envisagé que effectivement les
élections en mars pouvait pas se tenir
et que peut-être il fallait anticiper
quelque chose si elle était reporté au
mois de juin de manière à aider les gens
si d'aventuré la situation sanitaire
elle restée telle qualité de pouvoir
quand même exercé leur droit de vote
nous a été refusé moi je suis content
que la question revienne sur le tapis et
là je pense que ces trans partisan et
qu'on pourrait se mettre tous autour de
la table mais effectivement pour trouver
des solutions par se trouver des
solutions sécurisées mais il ya quand
même si je reprends l'exemple des états
unis depuis qu'ils font le vote par
correspondance et jamais des fraudes
avérées et la dernière sélection très
sensible à dire c'est en millions
d'américains qui ont voté par
correspondance
voilà ce qu'on trouve un système chose
qu'on trouve un système parce que là
c'est encore une fois conclure sur ces
élections moi ce qui me gêne le plus
c'est le double la double échéance
compromis les mêmes jours si on avait pu
décorer les deux déjà ça aurait facilité
la vie à la fois des citoyens et surtout
des élus parce que l'organisation et
c'est pas jean-françois que je vais dire
est qu'il va contredire
l'organisation de ces élections va être
très très con très compliquée j'en ai
bien peur surtout pour les communes
rurales 1 alors jean françois est au
dessus de ça mais même pour lui c'est
compliqué alors on va passer au dernier
chapitre de cette émission assez
rapidement de la démocratie on va parler
aussi du sondage
évidemment qu'ils placent valérie
pécresse largement en tête aux élections
régionales mais il faudra peut-être
aussi parlé de comment faire mieux vivre
la démocratie dans les départements dans
les régions mais je voudrais qu'on
s'attarde un petit peu à ce sondage qui
est parue dans le parisien
dimanche qui donne valérie pécresse
largement en tête avec 34% la surprise
presque c'est que le front national est
en deuxième position alors qu'il n'est
pas parce que là si vous me permettez
patrice sur ce sondage est la deuxième
position de jordan bardella je pense
qu'il a grillé pas mal de cartouches
chez vos confrères de bfm j'ai protesté
hier ou avant-hier
quand on lui a demandé le chiffrage de
son projet ou même question un petit peu
plus précise sur ce qui était la région
et ses compétences
ça a été la noyade à peu près similaire
à celle qui a connu sa patronne marine
le pen dans le débat face à emmanuel
macron avant l'élection présidentielle
donc voilà après ça sera ça sera aux
électeurs de juger mais là beaucoup
c'est un vrai naufrage pour quelqu'un
qui veut travailler de la région
oui mais si on regarde les
préoccupations des français toujours
selon ce sondage c'est un la délinquance
de l'environnement 3 l'immigration c'est
à dire que d'aider des thèmes sur
lesquels leur assemblée nationale et et
à ses enfants parlent beaucoup en tout
cas vous n'êtes pas surpris non pas sa
deuxième position et par la faiblesse au
fond de la gauche
en tout cas au premier tour puisque les
efforts appliqué il ya cinq ans ça
s'était joué c'était assez ric-rac là la
victoire de valérie pécresse un âne
perdriau alors oui alors patrice
l'achètera que vraiment si tu veux on a
on a le résultat de la culture pécresse
c'est à dire que l est pas libre pour
rien c'est vrai que c est là l a amené
une autre culture politique dans le
panorama
régional et français c'est à dire
l'action l'efficacité s'engage et
surtout faire ce qu'on a dit ce qui est
quand même pas banal en politique un et
on voit qu'elle a au bout de cinq ans hu
et nommément de résultats concrets pour
le quotidien des franciliens
par ailleurs elle a très très bien géré
ça sa région deux milliards d'économies
sur cinq ans en inversant complètement
la courbe du fonctionnement et de
l'investissement
c'est à dire que cc c'est une région qui
a économisé pour réinvestir massivement
sur tout ce qui était un peu laissé à
l'abandon depuis 17 ans donc moi ça ne
m'a pas étonné c'est vraiment la
traduction de sa politique pragmatique
et à la fois pragmatique et sécuritaire
c'est à dire que vous disiez c'est un
d'effectivement des grands critères je
pense qu'elle a été très très très ferme
et très engagé alors que la sécurité
n'est pas une compétence directe de la
région elle s'y est engagée avec
frédéric péchenard dès le début avec des
mesures qui compense d'ailleurs le
déficit des mesures de l'état sur les
commissariats les équipements de police
municipale la vidéo protection etc
je pense qu'en fait c'est tout ça qui
qui qui fait qu'elle a calé largement en
tête
peut-être qu'on a une vision déformée
parce qu'à une division quand même de la
gauche et des écologistes entre pulvar
hautain et bayous et la gauche reste
encore si elle était unie elle reste
encore assez forte en ile de france
oui mais elle ne sera pas eu ni un mot
parce qu'il faut qu'on se quitte
nombreux de milliers d françois vivier
pour répondre à une paire brio la gauche
nous invite
certaines turpitudes la nonne union du
premier tour peut se transformer en
union sacrée au deuxième tour 06 tous
donc je ne parierai pas sur l'anneau
d'union de la gauche
voilà donc et puis après il a écouté ces
élections elles sont intéressantes parce
que moi aussi je suis capable de dire
qu'effectivement économiquement
même si je ne partirai pas avec valérie
pécresse et vous savez tous
économiquement elle a fait le job
moi je lui reproche un petit manque
d'équité c'est mon point de vue
personnel entre les différentes parties
de l'île de france mais ça c'est mon
point de vue personnel
et puis un certain nombre de
transparence que certaines chansons
voilà sinon on peut pas dire que le
bilan économique de la région soit
négatif ce serait mentir que de le dire
j'en fasse envie de jouer en l2 reste
trois secondes non je pense qu'elle
incarne totalement cette région et en
cinq ans elle l'a amplement montré puis
surtout si on prend l'exemple de la
crise qu vie de réorienter 1 le navire
amiral aussi vite qu'elle l'a fait aussi
efficacement ça a été vraiment pour pour
montrer que les collectivités locales
sont davantage au rendez-vous même
parfois que l'état qui s'est trouvée
quand même assez empêcher il ya eu un
travail énorme de fait depuis depuis un
an
en dehors de ce qu'a rappelé anne à un
instant et puis j'apprends que bruno
sera pas avec nous je suis étonné moi je
pensais qu'on faisait parce qu'il avait
une majorité qui changera d'avis
peut-être peut-être rien il ya peut-être
un autre de tous et merci en tout cas
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat au nord fera jean-pierre combi je
pense aussi il faudra insister pour
savoir quels sont les pouvoirs des
conseils régionaux des conseils
départementaux question leur rôle leur
compétence ça sera très intéressant
aussi avant les élections qui auront
lieu en juin ou peut-être plus tard on
verra bien merci à tous merci
[Musique]